we're fast approaching the sales date of  the 3ds version the game is almost  complete but of course there are an  astronomical number of variables in a  game like this we have to be sure to put  enough people on the debug team and test  it correctly thank you for your patience  Python we've put all our focus into  getting the fighters items assist  trophies stages and enemy characters  ready and in the game and there are many  different modes besides the main smash  battles I won't go over them in detail  now but let me show you a bit of what's  in store for you  there are many more game elements that  we haven't introduced yet but I don't  think we can talk about them all before  we release however this will be our  first smash brothers game on a handheld  so I hope you're all looking forward to  super smash brothers for nintendo 3ds